hello everyone and welcome to a
brilliant game from round one of the
melt waters champions chester it's
magnus carlsen versus young shisht of
duda and i've had some guests over and
i've been uh getting requests for this
game uh all the time so now that my
guests have left the premises i decided
to show this game it's only the first
game of many that we are going to cover
on this tournament but let's start with
this one as it's really really amazing
so magnus with the white pieces opens
with d4 so it's uh
they will have four games in their match
there are rapid games like i said we
have a 15 minutes for all moves and then
you get a 10 seconds increment after
making each move and here for a win you
get three points for uh uh
loss of course you get zero so let's see
how this goes we have d4 by magnus
knight to f6 we have c for e6 knight to
c3 and d5 so just a normal queens gambit
declined c captures on d5 we have knight
captures on d5 going for the exchange
variation and knight to f3 by magnus we
have c5 by duda uh they're going for the
main line of the semitash and now e3 uh
we have c capture sunday for e captures
and now knight captures and c3 so uh
trading of a lot of pieces and pawns
here b captures and queen to c7 duda
goes after the c3 pawn and here uh the
position has been reached before and
usually you'll go bishop to d2 here but
magnus plays rook to b1 and so far it
seems that it is a new move so already
as of move 9 we have a completely new
game magnus is offering the c3 pawn and
he's doing so to get some rapid
development in if duda captures we're
going to play bishop to d2 force the
black queen back and after the queen
moves we're going to develop the bishop
let's say bishop to d3 and we're going
to get a lot of development in uh for
the price of one pawn so duda doesn't go
for this just yet he first develops the
knight tonight b to d7
and now comes bishop to d3 so again
magnus offers the c3 pawn but now it's a
little bit different because now
after the queen captures on c3 and
delivers check bishop to d2 is
impossible as the bishop on d3 would
hang so
duda did capture the opponent c3
delivered check magnus simply played
king to f1 and okay no castling for
magnus but let's see how do that
continues bishop to e7 he wants the
castle to safety very quickly and now h4
and this is the point of the this pawn
sacrifice
the rook will now be lifted to the h3
and from there you will be x-raying the
black queen and then ideas like bishop
captures an h7 rook captures queen might
come you know
handy so do the castles and rook to h3
so you don't have a castle king but the
king will be very safe on f1 or on g1
and the rook is coming to g3 to help out
with the attack against the black king
we have knight to f6 the knight belongs
here as you need a defender against the
white's attackers uh and now uh of
course you're you can't really just go
for anything yet your knight is still in
the way so you can pick up the queen
knights the e5 first and now you're
already threatening a move like bishop
captures on h7 and rook captures queen
on c3 so queen back to a5 by duda and
now comes rook the g3 so still for the
price of one pawn you have a very very
decent attack uh and here duda played
king to h8 but now believe it or not
this king to h8 is a losing move so feel
free to pause the video and win this
game for magnus yes already on move 15
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well incredible idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop
wrong bishop bishop the g5
and why is this so winning well because
black doesn't really have a move there
are too many attackers here and it's
impossible to stop all of them
of course we are going to eliminate the
defender of the h7 square and then our
queen is coming to h5 so how can you
prevent this uh to give you an example
of what could really go wrong let's say
you play something like knight that goes
back and then you
don't allow the this trait here uh we're
just gonna play queen to h5 attack the
h7 pawn and now if g6 uh i mean why not
we're just gonna sacrifice everything
bishop captures on g6 f captures knight
captures with check the king will have
to go to g7 and now knight back to e5
and there is no defense against the
checkmate whatever you could play it's
just game over the bishop moves the rook
exposes check there's not much you can
do here if king to h8 we still just
capture on e7 and there's no good move
here what do you play you could play
knight captures an e7 but just now queen
to e8 yes the position is that good now
we're threatening
a lot of different stuff we're
threatening queen capture so rook uh
we're also threatening knight captures
on f7 with checkmate because the rook
will not be able to capture the knight
and it doesn't matter if you capture the
queen knight to f7 is checkmate on the
spot and if you like we already
mentioned attack the queen now two rooks
are defending the back rank uh still
it's just uh knight to f7 checkmate
because again you can't really move this
rook so that's the idea that magnus has
with this bishop the g5 move and
congratulations of course to everyone
who found this so duda played h6 trying
to prevent this but now comes bishop
captures an h6 it's uh
incredibly uh ugly position for black
g captures on h6 and now comes queen to
f3 and he was in this position on move
18 that young sister of duda resigned in
the game as there is really nothing more
for black to uh do here uh and of course
that's why he resigns the queen to a
four queen captures on h6 is coming and
there is no defense against this uh if
you try something like uh knight to h7
you can even play queen captures on f7
and
even this is enough how do you how do
you prevent it is the queen cannot be
captured otherwise you're getting
checkmated here and other than that
there are no good moves here uh whatever
you play just loses terribly rook to g8
you just run into rook captures on g8 to
checkmate so
there are no moves that black can try
here
so uh what you could try after queen to
f3 maybe instead of knight to h7 is
something like rook to g8 but then you
uh leave the f7 pawn undefended and
again you run into this checkmate so
after queen to f3 there really isn't
anything for for black to try other than
some silly moves that would prolong the
game there is no defense against uh the
simple idea that that we just mentioned
uh uh that's the game that's a game one
of their match hope you guys enjoyed it
game two already has been played so
we're maybe we're gonna show that one as
well i hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank matthias binta
zachary bell mike pomeraning vast
knowledge uh and the dewey guy for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
uh impressive tournament and we can only
hope that all of the games are as
impressive as this one so thank y'all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day